yes that Oppenheimer review embargo Has
Lifted which means your feed is flooded
with Oppenheimer reviews so I do
appreciate you clicking on this review
in particular good news is it's going to
be a really easy review it's my favorite
kind of review
this movie is epic
[Music]
so Oppenheimer is written and directed
by Christopher Nolan as I understand
it's based off of the book American
Prometheus Stars Killian Murphy as J
Robert Oppenheimer who's known as the
father of the atomic bomb and this is a
biopic chronicling his life leading up
to the Manhattan Project him doing the
Manhattan Project and what came after
the Manhattan Project The Good The Bad
The Heavy it's here now Killian Murphy
is absolutely brilliant in this film as
J Robert Oppenheimer there's something
about Killian Murphy's eyes that pierce
absolutely that lens to those heavy
moments of regret and despair that he
feels later on in the film absolutely
whether it's with a stair or him
delivering dialogue his performance in
here is an absolutely
Soulful and heavy one those I should
backtrack because it doesn't start out
that way you know he starts out he's a
pretty relatable guy I mean true neutral
absolutely I like that about him and the
DND personnel reality scale he was true
neutral I just appreciate people like
that he's a flawed human but we're all
flawed humans maybe in different ways
but I was surprised at how relatable he
was which is why it makes it so much
worse when he becomes the guy who's like
I just wanted to help the world
and it's worse because of me because
it's easy to be like oh father of the
atomic bomb but it's like yeah but what
does that do to somebody what does that
do to the person who made the device
that killed that many people someone
who's not a military mind he's a
scientist Killian Murphy makes you feel
all of it he's always been an incredible
actor but this is the kind of
performance that an actor gives that is
truly special everyone in the movie
actually did a great job it's a packed
cast I cannot logistically list off the
entire Supporting Cast here Emily Blunt
Jason Clark Robert Downey Jr Matt Damon
and more there there are people in this
movie I Didn't Know were in this movie
it's like you two kind of shows how many
people just want to work with
Christopher Nolan at this point I think
that's great but also Robert Downey Jr
another amazing performance it's one of
those performances I don't logistically
know the exact number I don't know the
how many minutes of screen time he had
it's like ever since I learned Anthony
Hopkins had like 15 or 16 minutes the
screen time inside them through the
Lambs I always question that I don't
know why it's just a me thing from then
on I don't think he had a lot of screen
time but when I think of the movie I
absolutely am going to think of him and
his performance I love the fact that
Robert Downey Jr doesn't have to work a
day in his life and at that point
sometimes actors will be like yeah I can
phone it in get a paycheck it'll be fine
Robert Downey Jr must have more money
from those [__] you Marvel paychecks
than Heisenberg at this point no I'm not
talking about the German scientist I'm
talking about the fictional drug kingpin
and the dude's still like I'll clock on
an amazing performance and knock it out
of the park I don't have to but I want
to it's incredible to watch and what I
loved most about this what gripped me is
this feels like a cinephiles film it
feels like a film for film fans for the
love of Cinema and the Art of Cinema and
that Francis Ford Coppola Bram Stoker's
Dracula kinda way you know that movie
grabs me one of the reasons it does
anyway is because the visual effects in
that movie are all in camera effects
they're all practical and I'd heard that
Flex for this movie for Oppenheimer no
CGI anywhere in this movie and I
appreciate that it's kind of funny how
the flex is flipped or it used to be
like this movie has 3 000 CGI shots
that's the flex now the flex is the
opposite it's reverse now the flex is
zero and that's as cool as it gets and
it's not just for the nuke scene like I
thought it was gonna be like okay the
new scene is going to be practical
that's cool not with a nuke other
explosives but okay it's going to be
practical but it's not just that there
are scenes when oppenheimer's in his
head showing how he views the world what
he thinks about you see space Supernova
he thinks about Quantum Theory you see
atoms whizzing around it's easy to not
even think about it when you're so used
to movies having CGI but when you see
moments like that with practical effects
and it feels practical it feels tangible
it feels like it's something in the
world it's completely different it's a
magical experience I appreciated and
connected with the film on a level I
wasn't expecting to because of the
absence of CGI in scenes and shots that
otherwise would have had CGI Christopher
Nolan's the type of director who
inspires people to be directors things
like that are why as for the nukes scene
I don't know about you I love seeing
nukes in movies it's just a fun thing in
any other movie I'd be like yeah the
nuke it's coming let's do it I didn't
feel like that in here and I appreciated
that I love the fact that when it's
leading up to the bomb the movie doesn't
really logistically revolve around that
it is about Oppenheimer it's properly
titled it's about him and the work he
did and the aftermath of it not that one
thing he did but when it was leading up
to the bomb you feel the fear in the
room the anxiety the tension I love the
fact that Christopher Nolan was like
yeah you're looking forward to the bomb
we're gonna make it look cool but that's
not what it's important the thing I
remember from that scene is the look on
Killian Murphy's face while he's
watching it It's the reaction of
Oppenheimer that's important Oppenheimer
wasn't overshadowed in his own film and
his own biopic by the bomb I feel like
it'd be easy for that to be the case I
will say the last hour or so of this
film relies on a lot of exposition it
deals with the government and
Oppenheimer and you're hearing about
things that happened but you're not
necessarily seeing those things I would
have liked to have seen those things but
if it showed those things this movie
would be five hours long as opposed to
three the last hour or so of this film
could be its own film it could be a you
know sneaky government paranoia
courtroom drama but technically not a
courtroom drama but still the vibe of a
courtroom drama type film I mean it's
hard to condense a man's life who did
all this did so much and dealt with so
much after the Manhattan Project into a
three-hour film it's a great three-hour
film that works well for its run time
and actually tells more than you would
think they could put into this three
hour run time the musical score was
amazingly haunting and swells what it
needs to it's absolutely impactful there
are a couple moments of tension in here
with the musical score absolutely
knocked it out of the park but what I
liked about the audio mixing with the
musical scores from Christopher Nolan
movies recently of the audio's been a
bit uneven and the musical score is kind
of overridden the actors voices and the
dialogue couldn't really hear what was
going on so clearly this movie does not
have that problem I appreciate that I
don't mind saying this is Christopher
Nolan at his heaviest we've had some
good times we've had some action
Adventures but if someone said this is
Nolan going for his Oscar I wouldn't
argue it but I would add yeah and the
cool thing is it doesn't feel like he's
trying for the sake of that you know how
it is some Oscar bit you're like uh yeah
why not just beg for it this is just
Christopher Nolan making good dramatic
stuff the story performances filmmaking
editing all top tier it's a visually
beautiful epic tragedy and it is
awesome tacular
[Music]
I already want to see it again because
the screening wasn't in 70 millimeter
IMAX it was 70 millimeter film not IMAX
I really want to see this in IMAX
it's as simple as that all right so
Oppenheimer have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]